margaret taylor green is however she's a
member of congress from georgia and
we're happy to have her join us tonight
congressman thanks so much for coming on
selling off
one of america's most valuable assets to
china a company to add insult to injury
that his son was invested in
why is no one saying anything about this
well i'm not sure tucker i think it is
absolutely outrageous and so do the
american people the one role that is
most important for the president of the
united states is to protect our
country's national security our
strategic petroleum reserves are just
that our national security when it comes
to oil the very important resource that
we have that fuels our economy helps us
drive our cars and and petroleum also
feeds over 6 000 products things
americans rely on every single day but
joe biden has been selling off a million
barrels of oil every single day and
we're down to 434 million barrels of oil
america consumes just around 19 million
barrels of oil per day we cannot we
cannot sustain this it is putting us in
danger and by our tracking he has sold
over 7 million barrels of oil to china
china our number one threat that wants
to conquer us wants to become the number
one superpower in the world and because
of that tucker it is imperative that
when republicans take back congress that
we have to hold hold joe biden
accountable for this because he's
planning on selling more oil out of our
strategic pullium petroleum reserves
again starting in october so i'm
introducing articles of impeachment
against joe biden on monday because of
this outrageous move that he has
continued to make and putting our entire
country in danger
so
he's doing it now or in september next
month is october the month after that if
i'm if i'm following it correctly would
be november the first tuesday in which
is his pivotal midterm election so he's
doing this for political reasons to keep
gas prices low before people vote
absolutely our strategic petroleum
reserves are not meant to lower gas
prices for november elections they're
meant to be a national
security emergency supply for all
americans but joe biden is abusing it
and he's putting our entire country in
danger and because of that we're not
going to have any more oil left he's
selling it to our enemies and foreign
countries all over the world joe biden
has to be impeached and we must do it
yeah it's and it's not his i know this
guy has lived at public expense for his
entire adult life but he doesn't own
that it belongs to the public and he
can't just sell it to china this is just
too it's just too crazy to continue well
i appreciate those are your business
partners well you're that's those are
his business partners for sure yes
marjorie taylor greene of georgia
joining us tonight thank you
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight